Bây giờ, chuyến thằng Mỹ, tổng thống hành Quốc li trên miân khẩn lên,
sông khó có thể chức nhận yêu cầu của Washington về việc mưởng giống phạm vì vật đậm của lực bự Mỹ
đồng chủ tảnh này. Ông chưa rằng vẫn đề tính linh hoạt chính lợp của 20% nghiệm
năm 2020 tại Hàn Quốc không phải là điều có thể đồng thật ngày lập tất.
Đồng thấy này sẽ sẽ chung buổi cạnh Mỹ, thúc đời hiện tại hóa liên mình với Hàn Quốc,
bao gồm việc tăng chi tưu của phòng và tái cơ cầu lực lợp.
Chính quyền tổng thống luôn nâng tra muốn nâng cao vai cho của suôn trong khôn khổ ăn liên
của vực. Theo kêu hại, lãnh đạo Mỹ vàng Quốc sẽ có cuộc gặp thực định tại nhà trắng ngày
Hàn Lần Thánh Tắm. Đi đường xem là cơ hội để hả bên thảo luật về định hướng chính lượng
lông sai bị nhiều lĩnh vực cùng quan tâm.